we're going to begin with a story I know
most people that I know are talking
about that hazardous air it's affecting
tens of millions of Americans look take
a look at these pictures because this is
New York City this morning
and this is a United States capital in
Washington D.C
I can't get over this the haze and the
smoke fueled by hundreds of wildfires in
Canada many that are still burning out
of control and take a look at these
pictures these are from yesterday where
you can see an eerie orange Haze over
parts of the Northeast including right
here in New York City where Health
officials recommended that people wear a
mask again and to give you a sense of
just how fast the smoke rolled over
Manhattan yesterday this image shows a
relatively thin layer of smog this was
at 11 o'clock in the morning
so take this in and this is the same
area just three hours later when it was
nearly impossible to see the skyline I
thought is there an orange filter on
your screen no there is not this is how
bad it was if you look at these images
side by side you can see how much the
conditions changed in just a few hours
Lilia Luciano joins us now she's near
the Brooklyn Bridge Lilia I was so I was
hoping hoping you'd be wearing that
Mouse this morning so I'm glad you're
following the rules good to see you good
morning what can you tell us
good morning Gail well I'm going to tell
you about this neighborhood because I
live here I love this walk under the
Brooklyn Bridge my favorite thing is
when you walk around the corner here you
see the Statue of Liberty it's quite
shocking on any day she's usually
cleared today she's getting quite a bit
of privacy
they're not good in the air even now I'm
going to tell you the aqi I just checked
is above 220 that means that it's very
hazardous right now you do see this
Skyline yesterday you couldn't very
hazardous means it affects everybody not
just people with pre-existing conditions
yesterday of course was far worse to
give you an idea the aqi tops at 500 but
yesterday officials here said it reached
484 that's the air quality index which
registered New York as the worst air
quality of any major city in the world
a heavy layer of smoke covered New York
City in a dark orange glow Wednesday
more than a dozen states faced air
quality alerts with the haze obscuring
the Statue of Liberty as well as
downtown Philadelphia and historic
landmarks in the nation's capital all
New Yorkers should limit outdoor
activity to the greatest extent possible
in New York mayor Eric Adams said the
air quality was at its worst since the
1960s on Broadway the conditions
prompted two musicals to cancel their
shows the New York Liberty postponed its
WNBA game and the Yankees rescheduled
their matchup with the Chicago White Sox
turning away some fans at the stadium
definitely for the air quality it should
be the right decisions it all comes
after an unusually early and intense
start to Canada's Wildfire season more
than 400 wildfires are burning across
the country over half of them still out
of control nearly 9.4 million Acres have
burned in 2023 that's roughly 15 times
the average according to Canada's
minister of emergency preparedness this
is perhaps the worst year that we have
experienced with wildfires as long as
we've been keeping records this is a you
know visceral reminder of the climate
crisis that's in front of us Vijay Lemay
is a senior scientist with the national
resources defense Council he warned that
as climate change makes the weather more
extreme the public health risks grow in
this case he pointed to elevated levels
of PM 2.5 toxic microscopic particles
that are carried by the Wildfire smoke
we have never seen over the past two
decades PM 2.5 levels like they are in
New York City we have National limits on
the type of air pollution that is
legally allowable we're seeing air
quality levels that are you know three
to five times higher than that National
limit
and the greatest risk are young children
the elderly people with pre-existing
conditions but everybody should wear a
mask glad
it does not look good out there Lilia
thank you very much